[Música]
eu não tenho exatamente uma ideia mais
uma proposta pra vocês
a proposta de uma descoberta uma
descoberta que venho fazendo há 27 anos
na companhia de geólogos e paleontólogos
e alunos e escrevendo livros ilustrados
por talentosos para artistas e essa
descoberta que nós temos que fazer tem a
ver com este mundo claro
a escola é o nosso mundo é o nosso mundo
principal onde podemos aprender e nos
divertir
no entanto limitados pelos muros da
escola
nem sempre temos acesso a ele mas existe
uma verdade do pátio de cada escola
existe uma grande piscina olímpica que
nós parecemos não acreditar que está lá
é um momento é o espaço para diversão
intelectual mas as nossas crianças não
aprendem a nadar
simplesmente porque não mostramos a elas
que ela está lá nem todos vocês devem
ter percebido que o mundo que eu mostrei
anteriormente era o mundo pré histórico
e este brilho que vocês vêem no centro
do supercontinente pangea ilustra o
impacto de um asteróide de três
quilômetros que se chocou no estado do
mato grosso e os seus efeitos associados
a um grande organismo que ocorria no
norte do país já na sibéria 254 milhões
de anos atrás praticamente deletou a
vida multicelular em todo o mundo
este foi um dos eventos mais marcantes
da história da vida e aconteceu em
terras brasileiras
eu quero mostrar para vocês esta treina
que tem até aqui quatro pontos 55 metros
de comprimento e ela equivale a cada
metro dela equivale a 1 bilhão de anos
nós temos o nascimento da terra 500
milhões de anos depois os organismos nos
as bactérias se infectavam os oceanos a
3.4 milhões de anos
existem as rochas mais antigas da
américa do sul e elas estão no brasil a
2.4 bilhões de anos que está aqui nós
temos os mais antigos vestígios da vida
fácil a vida bacteriana em rochas do
brasil
os animais aparecem a 60 centímetros do
final 600 milhões de anos os primeiros
animais com esqueletos e eles aparecem
em rochas brasileiras
os dinossauros chegam a 230 milhões de
anos a seis centímetros no final foi
aquela grande extinção que todos sabem
que existiu e no último milímetro aqui
fechado pelo dedo e gabriela se nós
dividirmos por 3 1 num espaço
equivalente a um pouco maior que um fio
de cabelo está ao todo o tempo da nossa
existência
muito obrigado se eu perguntar pra vocês
o nome que vocês me digam o nome de um
dinossauro não precisa já sei o que já
sei quem vocês estão pensando
mas se eu perguntar pra vocês o nome de
um dinossauro que viveu em terras
brasileiras 80 milhões de anos atrás
bom este gigante de nove metros
os seus restos foram encontrados no
mesmo estado onde está a cratera do
grande asteróide que é o mato grosso
este gigante de nove metros é o
pycnonemosaurus que o seu nome difícil
significa mato grosso e se eu perguntar
então pra vocês que me diga o nome do
dinossauro mais antigo conhecido em
terras brasileiras
alguém se arrisca silêncio total
este é o padrão meus o corredor dos
pampas
um dos dinossauros mais antigos do mundo
não é surreal que não celebramos o fato
de que os dinossauros surgiram em nossas
terras 230 milhões de anos atrás
esta é a história que eu me referia
aquela grande piscina a qual nós
precisamos aprender a mergulhar
nós podemos transformar a nossa história
a nossa pra história no item da nossa
cultura
todos os países que investem e que
priorizam a educação transformaram a sua
própria para a história no item da
cultura assim como a música à literatura
o esporte e as artes à pré história
deles está em todo lugar
suas crianças aprendem na escola
a história geológica do seu país
a história geológica do seu estado elas
sabem os nomes dos animais
pré-históricos sabe que distanciam dos
animais que viveram cujos fósseis estão
preservados nas rochas abaixo dos seus
pés
nós temos praticamente o dever de
mostrar uma grande piscina para as
nossas crianças nas escolas
não podemos deixar essa nossa grande
piscina olímpica da pré-história bacia
nós também
são maravilhosas este é o tapuiassauro
os que viveu há 130 milhões de anos na
região norte de minas gerais
nossos dinossauros viram as primeiras
flores com seus perfumes evoluir em
nossas nos aurus devoraram os nossos
mais antigos ancestrais dos mamíferos
nossos dinossauros testemunharam o
nascimento da américa do sul e do oceano
atlântico
e mais eles deixaram milhões de pegadas
num imenso e área do deserto de tunas
que ocupou durante milhões de anos uma
grande parte do território nacional
estas areias deram origem a uma rocha
onde está hoje um dos maiores tesouros
da nossa história
o aqüífero guarani o terceiro maior
aqüífero subterrâneo do 1 10 anos atrás
uma exposição de animais pré históricos
levou a oca ao parque do ibirapuera
num período de três meses 550 mil
pessoas
as crianças adoram a pré história porque
é de pequeno que se aprende a nadar em
2018 um novo projeto
ilustrado nessas brilhantes e
ilustrações de rodolfo nogueira o nosso
pai o artista levará novamente oca os
dinossauros
só que desta vez toda a exposição são os
dinossauros e as paisagens brasileiras e
que quando nós levamos nossos filhos a
um restaurante para comer uma comida
gostosa
não é pra que eles se tornem chefes de
cozinha na mesa
nós não precisamos sobrecarregar nossos
filhos e nossas crianças levando os a
exposições
museus incentivando a leitura para que
eles se tornem necessariamente
cientistas não nós fazemos isso porque
nós temos a missão de educá los
nós temos a missão de ensiná los a se
divertir
nós temos que dar a eles a chance de
escolha o que eles farão com a vida
deles no futuro vamos deixar pra que
eles mesmos disse dão muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]